[Música]
[Aplausos]
fala galera que ricardo ventura
diretamente no tse que vocês já viram os
bastidores e agora vou mostrar o palco
pra vocês
tudo bem pessoal vocês não se incomoda
que eu vou fazer aqui uma transmissão ao
vivo da minha palestra porque eu vivo
muito conectado eu não sei quanto a
vocês mas o meu cotidiano é sempre o
smartphone na mão e os meus amigos
online
tanto é que eu posso ilustrar pra vocês
como que é que eu vivo com esses amigos
quando fui convidado para fazer essa
palestra aquilo tex eu precisava vir pra
o rio de janeiro que eu sou de são paulo
então precisava de uma passagem de avião
e aí eu pedi para o meu amigo aplicativo
resolver isso pra mim e ele escolheu a
melhor companhia o melhor dia o melhor
horário e foi tudo solucionado quando
chegou o dia de embarcar eu precisava
também de um show fé para me levar até o
aeroporto e aí eu pedi para o meu amigo
aplicativo resolver isso pra mim e ele
conseguiu o melhor show fé com o melhor
preço e eu não sei se irei conversar com
ele e ele já sabia onde ia me pegar onde
me levar
paguei pelo cartão cheguei aqui no rio
de janeiro precisava de um dos shows fé
mas é não sofrer carioca mas aí o meu
amigo aplicativo resolveu isso pra mim e
eu fui até o hotel
chegando no hotel a esse hotel inclusive
foi uma indicação de um amigo um amigo
aplicativo que fez um scanner da barra
da tijuca foi ricardo arrumei o melhor
lugar pra você eu falei então é esse
lugar que eu vou mas você tem uma opção
também você pode ser um carioca por
alguns dias e morar na casa de alguém eu
alugo um quarto pra você foi não aí já é
demais
deixa para o hotel e fui pro teu
chegando no hotel me deu uma forminha a
olhar um pouco minuto todo o rio de
janeiro toda a barra da tijuca no hotel
eu vou pegar que alguém vende que é o
amigo aplicativo amiga aplicativo onde
eu vou comer e ele me deu uma relação de
vários lugares para eu comer e foi muito
legal
orantes bares quiosques e eu fui pra lá
depois sobre o tempo ainda nesta tarde e
foi preciso conhecer lugares turísticos
eu preciso conhecer os lugares onde os
turistas vão condição na barra da tijuca
e eu perguntei obviamente pro meu amigo
aplicativo onde ir onde na barra da
tijuca e não só ele indicou como ele fez
um roteiro e um roteiro guiado
eu sabia exatamente onde eu tinha que no
finalzinho da tarde início da noite eu
pensei que tal tomar um chope com alguém
que tal jogar conversa fora
dividir uma porção de batata frita mas
eu sou casado porque senão teria os
aplicativos que arrumariam esse encontro
pra mim sem fazer força
mas eu fui pro hotel passei a minha
palestra e aí eu fiz o que é mais legal
do dia causar inveja eu postei todas as
minhas fotos nas redes sociais
e todo mundo desse desgraçado explicado
ventura na barra da tijuca e ainda eram
lights as minhas fotos comentário
dislike também na minha própria foto que
vai propor aumentar o número de likes e
aí comentei as próprias fotos e foi
muito divertido até o ponto que caiu a
minha ficha
eu pensei o seguinte olha que loucura eu
passei o dia inteiro cheio de amigos e
aplicativos que o pior ainda não fui só
eu porque no decorrer dessa trajetória
no aeroporto até alguns restaurantes nas
ruas nos bares
eu vi muitas pessoas cheios de amigos e
aplicativos inclusive aqui eu dei uma
olhadinha na de trás
tinham muitas pessoas assim olhando para
os amigos aplicativos e eu senti falta
saber do que do olho no olho
eu senti falta de estar presente de
verdade na frente de uma pessoa
esse cotidiano líquido fugaz fluido
rápido que resolve
ele é interessante mas ele pode estar
causando um dano irreversível que é o
maior
aplicar
tivo que o ser humano já instalou no seu
gene que é ler o outro entender o outro
sem ao menos emitir uma única palavra
e esse aplicativo na realidade ele teve
um peso enorme na história do ser humano
imagine que no tempo das cavernas antes
de proferir uma única palavra os nossos
ancestrais tinham que fazer conexões
descobrir se aquilo que estava chegando
perto dele era amigo ou inimigo se fosse
amigo eu podia compartilhar meu
conhecimento e as ferramentas que fosse
inimigo eu tinha que o cuidar da minha
própria ou então atacar para sobreviver
era diferença entre estar vivo estar
morto
e como eles fazem isso observando o
outro o jeito de andar
o jeito de das expressões o jeito do
movimento do corpo
o grupo unido o volume do grupo unido
significavam muitas coisas e acredite
aqueles que não tinham essa competência
sucumbiram não deixaram filhos acabou
gene aquele que sabia fazer isso
conseguiram gerar filhos e mais filhos e
mais filhos e chegaram em quem vocês
você já pensou nisso que você é é um
ascendente direto um descendente direto
dos homens da caverna mas ficar não é
que está esse aplicativo pois é nós
temos resquícios desses aplicativos com
a gente
eles estão se apagando a minha intenção
hoje aqui é reinstalá lo mas eu vou
mostrar pra vocês como ele ainda existe
no nosso gênio no nosso inconsciente não
tem mais consciência dele e para isso eu
vou mostrar alguma alguns cenários que
eu tenho certeza que vocês vão se
identificar
dá uma olhada nisso quando você está
numa sala de espera que você tem que
falar em sala de espera tem advogado
aqui tenho advogado tem médico aqui
também é médico legal não porque o
advogado acha que deus é médico tem
certeza
aí quando você marca com ele a consultas
duas horas que olha que ele atende a 6
não tem problema deixa aquelas revistas
velha pra gente lê falando o papa que
morreu na rodovia to o paulo 2o morte do
paulo 2º
há 15 anos a revista la aí você senta e
normalmente é um papo mas mesmo assim 60
do lado de um estranho é alô doutor
silva também algumas vezes você começa a
engatar uma conversa que começa assim a
bomba tinha como eu sou alguém dá um
soninho e agogô guardar um conforto e
aquilo vai mal a barba e dá aí o tempo
já foi embora se ele quer mais saber do
tempo que você pegou lá fichinha era a
fingir que pegou a 497 lata 97
mas aí tudo bem olha eu ao havaí daqui a
pouco você está contando com essa
pessoas coisas que você não conta em
casa já aconteceu isso
você começa a revelar de um sábio 50
tons de cinza e babá ela 497 o sinal a
497 hipnotizado jaua
aí sou eu que tenho que é tchau
tenho a w você quer continuar aquele
papo aconteceu isso com vocês de
encontrar um estranho e automaticamente
conseguir essa empatia o que é isso é
resquícios desse aplicativo instalado no
seu gênio você automaticamente conseguiu
fazer um scanner e percebeu esse é dos
meus ele tem coisas parecidas comigo e
aí eu me sinto confortável e aí o troco
experiência eu troco ferramentas mas o
inverso ricardo existe também de você
não se sentir bem
uma antipatia imediata assim porque
lembra que descobrir quem eram os
inimigos
eu vou dar dois exemplos pra vocês um de
homem ou de mulher pra você ea sua
namorada ou a sua esposa ann
e aí vem o seu amigo com a mulher ou a
namorada nova
saca ele acabou de arrumar ela vem e
fala hoje apresenta sua esposa e sai que
a nossa esposa fala é uma
ela só falou oi pra você mas eu sei que
não sente frio aquilo fácil mulher dada
eu não quero você perto dela carlos
augusto o seu amigo tendo poder você não
e o pior é que ela certa não é assim
né elas acertam e homem como é que é
homem normalmente ele estava dirigindo a
esposa do lado os dois se perdem não na
verdade a gente se perde ea esposa fala
bem
vamos lutar pra alguém tá bom tá aqui e
ali que a gente fala não porque não
porque ele não sabe como ele não sabe
não mas ele não sabe e não sabe que
aquele não aquele também não cooperar e
vão perguntar pra que ele já viu fazendo
isso porque a gente faz um scanner e já
consegue perceber pelo jeito de andar
pelo jeito se movimentar por vídeo olhar
para o carro da gente fala e se não esse
inimigo esse amigo
por isso que eu quero com você quer um
desafio agora com vocês aceita o desafio
não é boa eu quero reinstala esse
aplicativo com vocês aceitam então vamos
fazer uma bagunça agora que eu alguém
pode aumentar a luz pra mim do pau em
quem está assistindo de casa pode fazer
também seja onde for
talvez nessa esta fileira que tem uma
parede preta aqui fiquem de pé por favor
todo mundo de pé rápido de pé por favor
isso aí do lado de você tem pessoas não
têm essas pessoas levantem e olhem para
eles sem proferir uma única palavra
levantar em branco o amigão calma que
aquela fileira primeiro ataque o beleza
agora aqui a mesma coisa levanta aqui
levanta aqui ea outra olha pra casa
bandeira como é que é
levanta olha levanta e de lá começa a vê
lá primeiro levanta preta ali agora
fileira olha para ele e assim por diante
forma os seus pares rapidamente forma os
seus pares não precisa tirar a mão da
mão dela não vai pegar ainda que coisa
já está rolando uma comunicação não
verbal
vamos lá não é de olhar pra mim olha
para o seu parceiro de frente
olha o seu parceiro agora não é palavra
esqueça aquela aventura você está
sozinho quem está sozinho aqui pra
frente faz com ele aqui faz favor
levanta mas achou bem mas o homem mais
alguém mas alguém todo mundo com para
todo mundo com paok
preste atenção agora no seu parceiro
olhe para os olhos do seu parceiro não
olhe mais para mim olha para o seu
parceiro ok beleza seguinte
cala a boca ok é uma dinâmica não verbal
isso o seguinte olha o seu parceiro
agora encara o seu parceiro
às vezes a gente até tem vergonha de
fazer isso
mentalmente você disse para ele eu te
respeito e você me respeita
você percebe que já começa uma
comunicação surgir aí olha nos olhos
dessa pessoa e perceba que esses olhos
sou muito parecido com os seus olhos mas
ao mesmo tempo são diferentes o que
esses olhos já viram o que esses olhos
ainda querem ver quais lembranças que
esses olhos gostariam de relembrar
quais lembranças que esses olhos que
irão apagar de vez da memória e você já
começa a se comunicar sem dizer uma
única palavra
olhe para os lados dessa pessoa isso
olhe para os lados talvez rolou um
sorrisinho malicioso ou não o que esses
lábios já proferiram nessa vida que
esses lábios ainda vão proferir o que
esses lábios proferiram com palavras
doces que confortaram a vida de muita
gente que palavras rudes esses lábios já
se disseram e feriram muita gente
coloque a sua mão direita agora pra
frente coloca sua mão direita pra frente
isso um pouco mais baixa que deixa o seu
amigo ver a sua mão isso perto do umbigo
ele foi lá é ótimo
olhe pra mão de seu amigo é uma mão como
a sua mas ao mesmo tempo tão diferente
o que essa mão já construiu o que essa
mão já destruiu de quantas pedras
ela já te defendeu de quantas pedras ela
já tirou pega na mão de seu amigo agora
segura a mão de seu amigo engraçado que
eu não falei pra vocês se cumprimentarem
mas as mãos já começaram a se
cumprimentar sem dizer nada ouvem
chacoalhar de mãos continua segurando a
mão dos seus amigos
olhe para os olhos dessa pessoa vocês
viram quanta comunicação aconteceu sem
proferir uma única palavra
olha nos olhos dessa pessoa e diz o
seguinte eu te respeito
mentalmente você me respeita e por um
presente em forma de presente e por
gratidão
eu gostaria de finalizar essa dinâmica
te dando um abraço
se você sentiu que sim abraça
agora isso abraça pessoa agora vocês
acabaram de criar o abraço entre a
modernidade líquida fugaz com a maior
capacidade do ser humano que estar
presente ao outro pode se sentar e uma
coisa que eu quero que vocês saibam se
vocês quiserem levar para casa uma única
mensagem de carlos ventura é a seguinte
eu adoro esse cotidiano líquido eu adoro
os meus amigos aplicativos eles resolvem
a minha vida inúmeras vezes mas tem uma
coisa que eu jamais vou deixar de
deletar na minha mente no meu rádio é
que é o aplicativo todos os dias eu
penso nele seja mais humano ponto app
muito obrigado obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]